well if you've been listening to this
show over the past year you have heard
me on a few occasions Lament The Tipping
epidemic in our culture The Tipping
Scourge the outof control proliferation
of tipping everybody wants a tip Now
everywhere you go no matter how mediocre
their performance you've heard me talk
about this problem enough that you
certainly don't need to hear me talk
about it again right now uh I have made
my case everyone understands that when
it comes to tipping I am at the Tipping
Point but I need to broach the subject
one more time for what I promise will be
the last time at least for this month
for two reasons first so that I could
make that Tipping Point joke that
objective is complete second because of
this story which I find so annoying that
I am compelled by forces forces of
nature outside of my control to talk
about it in the daily cancellation the
stories from CNN quote uh thinking of
skipping on a door Dash tip do so at
your own risk warns a message being
tested by the food delivery provider if
you try to place an order through the
door Dash app without leaving a tip you
may get this popup orders with no tip
might take longer to get delivered are
you sure you want to continue the note
goes on Dashers can pick and choose
which orders they want to do uh orders
that take longer to be accepted by
Dashers tend to result in slow
delivery in other words tip your drivers
or be prepared to wait a long time for a
cold meal customers are then given the
option to add a tip or continue without
one so this is how bad the Tipping
plague has gotten every time I think it
couldn't get worse it gets worse now
companies are using blackmail to bully
you into tipping and they're demanding
the tip before the service is rendered
and we'll get back to that in a second
NBC had a report on this new system from
door Dash which is which it's rolling
out as a trial balloon to see just how
much customers hate it and customers
will hate it and they'll do it anyway
NBC spoke to a door Dash driver who uh
made his case for why we should tip him
here's what he
said it hurts your
feelings it hurts your feelings more
when they tip you a penny the food
delivery service added this pop-up
disclaimer as part of a pilot program
it's 5
miles
and maybe there's a dollar tip
maybe but it's just
like I don't
know are you going to take that order no
I'm not going to take that definitely
not going to
take it hurts his feelings when you
don't tip so make sure you tip or the
man on the bicycle might start crying
which is maybe the best case against
tipping that could possibly make I I'd
want to give that guy an anti-tip if
that's possible I want him like I want
him to pay me money that's how that's
that that's what should happen there I
don't know if it's I wish there was a
negative tip option for somebody like
that by the way business is booming for
door Dash they uh they had 540 million
orders last quarter which is a 24% jump
uh year-over-year according to CNN
revenue is up 27% and yet door Dash like
so many other multi-billion dollar
companies expect us to pay their
employees for them something that you
would think we're already doing by
paying for the service in the first
place but no door Dash demands that we
pay for the service and then also pay
extra for the worker who is performing
the
service this is why It ultimately cost
you $87 to have a hamburger and fries
delivered to your house from a
restaurant three miles away because
you're paying for the food and you're
paying for the service and you're paying
for the worker rendering the service and
these are all three separate charges and
then you're also paying the government
so just to get the hamburger you got to
pay for you're paying the restaurant
you're paying the company you're paying
the the worker you're paying the
government it starts to feel excessive
to a lot of people which is why they may
choose not to tip but now door Dash is
actively threatening you with
deliberately poor service if you attempt
to order a pizza without having to
mortgage your house to pay for it this
is how insane this situation has become
and door Dash and Uber Eats they're
perfect little microcosms of the Tipping
problem as a whole the incentive
structure has been thrown wildly out of
balance now it used to be that you would
tip in certain limited circumstances as
a reward for exemplary service now
you're not only expected to tip everyone
in every service job but you're also
expected to tip before the service has
been performed so you know you may tip
your door Dash driver 20% only to get
your order 30 minutes past expected
delivery time anyway and your food is
cold and like someone took a bite out of
your sandwich all right and you already
tipped them cozy Earth sheets are the
softest most luxurious sheets I've ever
owned my wife and I have their white
bamboo sheets on our bed these bamboo
sheets are temperature regulating help
us both sleep better every night if
you're a hot sleeper and your spouse is
a cold sleeper you'll need these sheets
especially on these cold winter nights
cozy Earth sheets offer an array of
sizes and 11 colors to match your Unique
Style and preferences their sheets are
made to withstand the test of time my co
Earth sheets get softer and softer with
every wash but don't just take my word
for it they have over 5,000 happy
customer reviews on their site what are
you waiting for cozy Earth offers a 100
night guarantee so there's no harm in
trying them out make every night a cozy
one with cozy Earth right now you'll
save 40% off your next purchase with
promo code walsh4 cozy earth.com that's
promo code walsh4 cozy.com the tip has
has become an Act of coerced generosity
which it never was before and it was
never meant to
be the same thing applies even to coffee
shops and other places that now ask for
tips the first problem is that they're
asking for a tip in the first place the
second is that most of the time they're
asking for the tip before they have
completed the service that they're
supposed to perform they haven't even
given you the coffee yet and they're
asking so it's not even it's like it's
bad enough to ask for a tip when all
they're doing is just handing you a
coffee they're asking for the tip before
they even do that so they could figure
out a way to screw that up and you've
already tipped them for it just the
other day I went to a coffee shop uh
ordered a regular coffee for myself and
then a fancy specialty coffee for my
wife and you know she always wants a
fancy coffee I always tell her look your
fancy coffee it's going to take longer
okay I just get you a regular Cofe it's
all the same anyway it's just caffeine
she wanted the fancy coffee fine
employee flips over the the dreaded iPad
with the tip amounts and uh there was no
friendly request for a tip no
friendliness at all actually she barely
said a word through the whole
transaction she didn't say anything like
I just totally and then just and then
just flipped it over and walked away
like
really and then uh and then you know
expecting me to reward her for doing as
close to nothing as you possibly could
although to be honest I think I'd prefer
that they just silently flip the screen
over than do the other thing that they
usually do which is you know they flip
it over and they say it's going to ask
you a couple questions no no it's not
going to ask me a couple questions it's
going to ask me one question and you and
I both know what that question is stop
trying to disguise your panhandling like
it's some kind of survey you're
conducting imagine if a homeless guy
with a sign begging for money walked up
to you shoved the sign in your face and
said the same thing
just going to ask you a couple
questions anyway I want I wanted to go
hit the no tip option as I always do
these days but because I'm dumb and
clumsy I accidentally hit the wrong
button and I tipped a dollar tragically
and um this again was before the service
had been completed I did not have the
coffee in hand at this point and 20
minutes later after having already
tipped accidentally but still I'm still
standing there waiting for my wife's
fancy coffee which was not nearly so
fancy that it had to take 20 minutes to
make I had tipped ahead of time for a
service that ended up being extremely
poor this is how it goes now but when
you think about it the epidemic of
tipping is is it's not happening in a
vacuum it didn't come out of nowhere
it's just the latest iteration of forced
charity in our culture this is
essentially the welfare state now making
its way into the service industry you
know we have lived in a culture of
entitlement for a long time it's no
surprise that it's manifesting itself in
this way now and the biggest problem
with the forced or coerced charity
whether it's a government entitlement
program or a pop up on door Dash
threatening you with cold food if you
don't tip your driver ahead of time or a
sullen scowling cashier flipping an iPad
over expecting a tip for doing literally
nothing in all of these cases the
coercion tactics may prove profitable
for those wielding them but they don't
do what willful voluntary charity and
generosity does when somebody chooses of
their own free will to be generous free
of any emotional blackmail or coercive
tactics or force their charitable Act
Naturally breathes gratitude and
connection and
appreciation when somebody is generous
to you because they chose to be generous
it lifts both both you and them up in
ways that that go beyond the
financial but that's not how it works
when somebody is forced or manipulated
or pressured into charity in that case
it makes the giver understandably bitter
and resentful while the receiver only
becomes more entitled and spoiled
everybody is worse off The Giver most of
all because he's the one losing money
but both parties giver and receiver both
walk away from the exchange with a
negative attitude about
it that's why as I have often remarked
we're seeing tipping go up while quality
of service goes down the more that
service workers are tipped the more lazy
and entitled they see to
become and the more annoyed and broke
their customers
become everybody loses in the end even
if the service worker makes a few bucks
out of the deal companies like door Dash
are driving this problem maybe more than
anybody else and that is ultimately why
door Dash is today
cancelled if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed